nicolas glières enseignants et membres
des stylos rouges clavières bonjour et
merci d'être en direct avec nous sur rt
france alors viens de l'entendre le
ministre de l'éducation qui garde le
même cap en cas de reconfirme en les
écoles resteront ouvertes
le ministre a toutefois précisé que la
situation permettait à la continuité
scolaire comment est-ce que vous
accueillez ses déclarations il est
toujours sur les mêmes lignes
concrètement il ne veut pas dédier une
espèce d'orgueil d'arrogance à ne pas se
dédire
j'invite tout le monde à regarder les
chiffres de santé publique france sur
les écoles des établissements scolaires
en général les chiffres du ministère de
la santé qui contredisent totalement ce
que dit monsieur blanc caire qui
continue à mentir
les écoles sont des clusters il y as
danger pour les enfants leurs parents
leurs grands parents pour une nous nos
familles nous enseignants avaient sage
surveillants rien n'est fait comme
d'habitude on va encore peut-être
choisir une règle du en même temps c'est
à dire ne rien décider du tout c'est
bien la ligne de monsieur macron sait on
fait rien on ménage un peu tout le monde
de sorte que rien ne se passe et le
virus continue à nous pourrir la vie
on continue à détruire les restaurants
les cafés les salles de concerts et
spectacles qui avait pourtant des
protocoles beaucoup plus strictes que
les établissements scolaires je rappelle
que nous n'avons aucune distanciation
sociale et ce n'est pas une vue de
l'esprit en une à 40 centimètres les uns
des autres en classe - dans les couloirs
j'ai eu le coach ide en décembre que
j'ai attrapé à mon collège rien n'est
fait pour nous protéger
c'est un mensonge c'est un mensonge
d'état je rappelle que les gens qui ont
organisé une soirée clandestine ont tout
de suite été mis en examen risquent des
peines de prison quid de monsieur blanc
car à cause duquel des milliers de
personnes tout malade est certaine on
meurt voilà qu'en est il de la justice
en france
pour l'instant il ne touche pas les
puissants il serait temps que ça change
alors quelles actions prévoyez-vous on
sait que le principal syndicat du
premier degré appellent à la grève
générale alors tous les syndicats
pratiquement tous les vrais syndicats
disons hormis les dunes 5 est vendu au
gouvernement appelle à la grève le 26
janvier mardi donc en particulier pour
nos salaires puisque nous sommes
toujours extrêmement mal payés nous
allons toujours perdu 40
pour son pouvoir d'achat depuis 1983 gel
du point d'indicé
aucune prime de risque alors que nous
sommes le seul métier hors médicale à
être autant ni face au co vide être mis
en danger sans aucune sécurité régnant
pour nous pas un centime
rien n'est fait donc nous nous allons
manif enfin nous allons faire grève
nous n'avons pas particulièrement à des
manifestations puisqu'elle serait
dangereuse vu la situation ça serait
absurde faut être cohérent mais en tout
cas nous appelons la grève nous espérons
qu'elle sera massive
nous verrons bien mais nous nous luttons
pour les salaires notre mot d'ordre chez
les stylos rouges ces salaires moyens
respect le respect commence par être en
étant bien payé leur espèce aussi être
entendu monsieur blanc qu'un nous a
jamais entendu ni détruit l'école cette
crise sanitaire at elle sur les élèves
eux mêmes on sait que pendant le premier
confinement beaucoup étaient obligés de
rester chez eux alors que l'école
parfois était un échappatoire
alors le gros souci c'est que ça ça
concerne une minorité ça veut pas dire
que c'est pas grave attention je ne
dirai jamais cela mais en fait pour 4 %
des élèves décrocheurs on va contaminer
la population française on va continuer
à répandre le virus
ce n'est pas sérieux et c'est une
manipulation de ces catégories
c'est une honte on utilise ces 4 % pour
ne rien faire et pour en fait suivre la
doctrine libérale du gouvernement
je rappelle que le gouvernement ne
protège pas l'économie réelle reste au
cinéma etc mais protège uniquement les
finances des entreprises continuent à
faire des réunions au présentiel dans
mon cercle familial proche ça a été un
cluster une grande entreprise a continué
les réunions présentiel ya quelques
semaines ça continue partout les
entreprises ne s'adaptent pas elle
refuse d'adapter les horaires de travail
ça paraît complètement aberrant elles
qui sont les chantres de l'adaptabilité
voilà ça serait une solution simple
décalons les horaires de travail les
parents pourraient s'occuper des enfants
nous demandent les deux me groupe on le
martèle depuis juin pour éviter le
confinement pour éviter la fermeture
peut-être on va être obligé d'arriver à
la sphère de fermeture des écoles à
cause de monsieur blanc caire mais aussi
à cause du déni des parents ne veulent
pas se retrouver avec leurs propres
enfants sur les bras et là il ya
vraiment une question à se poser est ce
que c'est pas plus important la sécurité
la santé publique que d'avoir ses
enfants
pendant trois semaines à la maison ou un
jour sur deux par exemple ou mieux nous
c'est ce qu'on demande depuis longtemps
dans l'intérêt des enfants justement
beaucoup d'enfants sont malades moi j'ai
plein d'accent d'absents pour cause de
coded donc ça continue ça se répand les
chiffres sont faux je le répète il
suffit d'aller voir sur santé publique
france et même les chiffres du ministère
de la santé contredisent monsieur
blancard merci beaucoup
nicolas ville fière d'être intervenu sur
notre antenne ce matin je rappelle que
vous attendent enseignants et membres
des stylos rouges
merci à vous